The R-rated Logan rips, wrenches, and roars
its way through its 137-minute run-time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
Thanks to the success of Ryan Reynolds' brilliant
R-rated Deadpool, we now have Logan, one of
the best ever X-Men movies and definitely
the very best Wolverine movie, a film that
both the awesome Hugh Jackman and comic book
fans deserve.
Yes, the year in celluloid superheroes started
out great with the fun-loving parody that
was The Lego Batman Movie, but standing, snarling
180-degrees away from that film's tone is
Logan, which takes the high bar set by Lego
Batman, tears it to shreds, and puts another
even higher bar in its place.
Star Hugh Jackman and director James Mangold,
who already greatly improved on the X-Man's
first solo outing with The Wolverine, promised
something different with this new movie and
they weren't kidding.
Mangold and his co-writers Michael Green and
Scott Frank have successfully ripped up the
comic book movie playbook and gone for a full-fat,
dark and moody western, that's ravishingly
shot in all its rusty, dusty glory by Gladiator
cinematographer John Mathieson, and effectively
scored by Marco Beltrami.
Of course, director Mangold's got form in
the western genre, having brought an excellent
remake of the classic 3:10 to Yuma to the
big screen.
And while Logan channels the likes of Clint
Eastwood's Oscar-winning Unforgiven, George
Miller's Mad Max series, as well as Hollywood's
Golden Age of Westerns, it also wears the
influence of the Man in Black, Johnny Cash,
firmly on its sleeve.
Which is hardly surprising, given that Mangold
was the director who gave us the Cash biopic
Walk The Line.
And Mangold's Logan movie doesn't waste time
when it comes to getting its adamantium claws
dirty.
In fact, it dives head first straight into
the kind of action you can expect throughout;
forget quick cuts away, this action is visibly
brutal, bloody, and 100% full-on, and certainly
earns its R rating.
Indeed, from start to finish, the whole film
is filled with WTF moments.
Props go to Logan's stunt team for numerous
incredible fight scenes, each one more flinch-inducing
and crazy than the last, yet each of which
feels so raw and authentic that they cleverly
hide the hard work that's gone into choreographing
and executing them.
And the movie's sound department have outdone
themselves too, especially when it comes to
the action scenes as the sound of those mutant
claws ripping and piercing through everything
in sight is spot-on as it's just perfectly
excruciating!
Plus there's some horrifyingly good visual
effects work from the movie's VFX team.
This Logan is untamed and untrammelled.
He may be totally vicious, but he's also scarred
and hurting badly.
We've not seen him quite like this in the
X-Men movies before.
And Hugh Jackman gives a pitch-perfect performance,
really making you feel just how worn-out,
run-down, and weary this Wolverine really
is.
And Dafne Keen may be a newcomer to the big
screen but as Laura, she matches Jackman's
superlative performance throughout.
She really is that good.
The way she moves, the way she attacks, the
way she eats, and the way she communicates,
all leave you in absolutely no doubt just
how feral her character is.
Add to that the fact that Keen is as good
at playing the humour and tender moments as
well as the more physical scenes, and we have
a real potential future star in our midst.
Actually, the quality of her performance reminds
me of the first time I saw Hailee Steinfeld
on the big screen in the Coen Brothers' True
Grit and also Millie Bobby Brown as Eleven
in Stranger Things.
As for Patrick Stewart as a 90-year-old Professor
X, what can I say?
Except that, just like Jackman and Keen, he's
exceptional, wringing out every last drop
of anguish, heart, and humour from the script.
Speaking of humour, Stephen Merchant brings
a nice dose of that to the film as the mutant-tracking
Caliban, a part he plays superbly.
While Boyd Holbrook puts in an effectively
nasty turn as Donald Pierce, who's out to
get Laura, along with Richard E. Grant's evil
scientist, who unfortunately doesn't get a
great deal to make a particular impression
with.
To sum up: James Mangold's Logan is a bold
and satisfying cinematic take on the much-loved
X-Men character.
In his final outing donning those adamantium
claws, Hugh Jackman skilfully steps up to
the challenge of creating a character and
a film that will likely be held up as benchmarks
for future comic-book to celluloid adaptations.
While Patrick Stewart and Dafne Keen join
Jackman in giving stand-out turns in a film
that never shies away from the nasty realities
of its world.
Make sure you see Logan on the big screen
as soon as you can.
As for me, I'll definitely be watching it
again.
Now, what are you looking forward to about
Logan, or if you've seen it, what did you
think of it?
And what other comic book characters would
you like to see get the R-rated treatment?
Let me know in the comments below!
I've got more Logan videos on the way, including
easter eggs in the movie, so turn on your
notifications for Flicks And The City to make
sure you catch all my latest videos!
And if you enjoyed this video, do share it,
and subscribe for more reviews, easter eggs,
and crazy movie and TV facts, some of which
you can check out by tapping or clicking the
screen here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!